[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur verlief welt ich
hatte im kühlschrank noch ein bisschen
pizzateig übrig und habe mir jetzt
überlegt was mache ich denn damit heute
gibt es raum fladen vielleicht kennt ihr
die auch als mittelalterliche
mittelalterlichen barden und zwar ist es
ein gebäck ähnlich pizza aber ein
bisschen auch flammkuchen also ein
zusammenschluss von beidem
und ja bist ein pizzateig schon auf
meinem basics wie gesagt vorbereitet und
mache jetzt eine basic creme ich zeige
euch mal kurz die zutaten 200 gramm
spannt 200 gramm joghurt da habe ich
jetzt eine zehnprozentige salz pfeffer
und chili und 300 gramm kaffee käse das
ist ein käse dem auch cars cavalese und
wir nämlich ganz gerne als ersatz firma
zu firma oder auch dort zum beispiel
weil er wirklich richtig toll schmilzt
und außerdem braucht jetzt noch ein paar
andere zutaten und da bünder jetzt mal
ganz kurz um einen kühlschrank und
schaue was daher gibt in meinem
kühlschrank habe ich folgende zutaten
gefunden
zucchini produkten fischer tel
lauf eingelegte chili etwas vierten käse
cocktailtomaten getrocknete tomaten rote
zwiebel grüne oliven und kapern
zuerst fröhlich jetzt alle zutaten für
die creme zusammen das heißt schmand und
joghurt
da kommen auch die kräuter mit rein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt stelle ich die creme und den käse
kurz zur seite und werden hier beträgt
nämlich schon vorbereitet habe kurz in
kleine portionen einteilen und flach
ausrollen
[Applaus]
die fladen habe ich jetzt mit hilfe von
endlauf backt rendsburger ausgerollt ihr
könnt aber natürlich auch ein bisschen
mehr verwenden
jetzt drücke ich sie einfach auf meine
back folie oder aufs papier
darunter habe ich ein lochblech und kann
jetzt erstmal alle auslegen und bisschen
mit der creme bestreichen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
für die erste variante verwende ich
jetzt thunfisch hat el kapern und rohde
triebel und da kommen jetzt die zutaten
einfach drauf und werden dann mit dem
käse bestreuen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für die zweite variante verwende ich
foto cocktailtomaten grüne oliven und
schlau und für die dritte variante nehme
ich sowie scheiben rote zwiebeln etwas
vierten käse eingelegte chili und
getrocknete tomaten und so können die
rams laden jetzt im vorgeheizten
backofen gebacken werden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt sind die rahmen fladen fertigt
jeden der küche riecht wirklich super
lecker und wir haben alle schon richtig
großen hunger
mein team und ich wir werden jetzt
mittagspause machen jetzt gibt's nämlich
die ramschladen ich glaube jeder hat so
seine eigenen favorit aber ich glaube
schneiden sie und jeder darf von allen
probieren oder so machen wir das
also falls ihr das rezept nach machen
möchtet dann schaut auf meinem blog
vorbei auf salehs - blog.de und wenn ihr
eine andere variation mache dann postet
sie auf jeden fall auf instagram dann
können wir nämlich auch nachschauen und
vielleicht schon feuer anregungen holen
also uns und euch einen guten appetit
[Musik]
[Applaus]